general election is just two weeks away
from today and clark county is now
starting to count the tens of thousands
of mail ballots they've already received
eight news now reporter kate houston is
live at the county election headquarters
now with the very latest hi kate
hi yes i'm here by the mail ballot
dropbox where we've seen a steady stream
of voters
all morning long inside election
department workers are counting ballots
just like these ones
as well as those sent through the mail
now today is the first day
they've been able to start counting the
ballots up to this point they were just
being processed
and verified election department staff
took the secured ballots out of the
vaults
and brought them over in these ballot
transfer boxes
observers sat and watched as workers
went through and fed each ballot through
the tallying system
the election department tells me they're
excited to get started that way they can
keep up with the amount of ballots that
they've received so far
we're over 100 thousand in mail that's
already been returned as of yesterday we
were up to 79
000 early voters in person so the
numbers looked good as far as a balance
between the mail and early voting at
this point
in order to make the counting process go
smoothly joe gloria the registrar of
voters who you just heard from
says everyone should be careful with
regards to their ballot don't spill
coffee on it or damage it
try to fold it up as best as possible
before putting it in the privacy sleeve
and make sure to sign the envelope so
that way it can be processed and counted
now if you're planning to fill out your
mail ballot you can always send it
through the mail or you can drop it off
at one of these drop boxes here now all
in-person voting sites as well as
election day voting centers
will be mail ballot drop-off sites as
well reporting from the clark county
election department kate houston 8 news
now